hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute in diesem spiel geht es darum dass
wir ein
zahnarzt sind glaube hier könnt ihr auch
hier inzwischen easy und norman preuß
eine frage natürlich normal charles mehr
brauchen wir nicht mieter wie vermieter
show matt cain und sitzkomfort braucht
reifen träume kommen jetzt kippt das
ganze mal okay wir können jetzt hier mit
unserer karte
wie komme ich denn jetzt zu den gebäuden
dahin kann ich mit meiner vielleicht
hätte ich mir wirklich das tutorial
durchlesen sollen es kann sein dass wir
hier hin
corny malten sie doch richtig aus
solidworks corp new adventures of money
making opportunity benita pursuit
exterior pcs und lieblings color ist
purple ok hätte ich wirklich mal das
tutorial spielen sollen meine haare sind
schlimm
ich gehe zum friseur das ist ja am
herzen wie sie das ist jetzt ihr
obersten richters jetzt kommen erst mal
hier ich kann nichts machen sekte kala
forderte die profis
ich glaube sie mochte perthel das heißt
wir nehmen per radar
ich hab sie komplett behandelt man sieht
keinen unterschied zu vorher als
nächstes können wir uns aber um diesen
riss hier unten da können wir dann die
ich versteh's nicht es denn jetzt kann
jetzt hier zahnpasta drauf packen und
dann werde ich das ganze
man kann nie genug zahnpasta haben und
jetzt schon die zähne putzen damit wie
komplett frei
warum ist das denn jetzt abgebaut wieso
sie dann uns unzufrieden kommen wir
geben jetzt einfach mal eine fette
spritze hier
wie kann ich denn nicht spitze geben
möchte jemand zu mir haben okay jetzt
haben wir los geht's erstmal hier das
begutachten dann hier das nehmen und
hier von 1 nach 2 und 2 3 und 3 4 und
dann noch hier
760 nur da oben ist auch noch mal ein
rich trainer machen war da ist sie aber
mal komplett die a1 auf zwei und zwei
auf drei und 3 auf 4 und 4 auf 5 und 5 6
und 6 7 und 7 klicken dreckig projekte
an dem du brauchst mir gar nicht sagen
ich kann auch hier direkt hier
ich bin so gut und die zähne rasieren
und ist das überhaupt ein rasierer
hauptsache sie macht erst mandac den
rockies auto
du brauchst mir gar nicht sagen level
complete 55 happy war die nur frau die
hat tatsächlich schreckliche szene ich
gebe mir jetzt mal übels höhe
die 100 prozent
wieso ging jetzt endlich kommen paktiert
und diamanten hier ein
wieso geht das denn nicht wahr 50
schnell noch die ganzen felder wo die
draufpacken dass ich das dings hin
packen soll pack ich da kann das nicht
mehr auf wenn jetzt mit dem ja und jetzt
noch schön den mount meter 66 prozent
der kombi sind bei mir mal alle
tatsächlich nicht so happy okay an
dieser stelle muss ich jetzt sagen dass
ich so einen patienten definitiv nicht
betreuen möchte vor allem weil er
klassische musik mag ich gehe weg zu dem
web und ich hoffe es kann sogar in new
york was machen hier
wenn euch das video gefallen hat oder
meine zahnarzt künste dann zeigt es mir
gerne mit einer bewertung und schreibt
mir die kandare vielleicht ob wir noch
mehr von solchen spielen kennt ja dass
videos jetzt vorbei können jetzt gehen